[Music]
heyo
happy Tuesday we're actually on time
we've done it we did it I thought of us
once
thank y'all for tuning to gamespot live
today we're gonna check out World War Z
we were given a code by Sabre
interactive we're gonna check it out now
caveat was I wanted to do co-op with Ben
but unfortunately currently World War Z
in general like across I think multiple
consoles are having problems with server
connectivity so yeah they've tweeted
that they're trying to figure out
however at least luckily I was actually
afraid I was like oh crap we're we
screwed like there's offline campaigns
that's good so all right you get to so
we're we're hanging out in the lobby
right yeah so you get to choose your
character you can you can choose between
them like five random or four characters
so it seems like the different chapters
have different locations and you play as
different people in each of them okay so
you get to pick from like four
characters for each one holes and then
you have your claw
oh there's your four and there's
chapters for each one yeah seems like
there's a range class classes which is
kind of like the the big thing I guess
yeah and then there's like skill trees
right yeah there's skill trees for each
one's like you can customize your class
and then boom when you get like actual
talent trees that you got to work your
way through to meze level other yep and
then on first glance you're gonna go
Hellraiser yeah just like the demos
expert I'm feeling I'm feeling like a
good thing in this game will probably be
explosions because a lot of the stuff
they've been building up is the fact
that zombies like swarm on top of each
other all right we'll see how that goes
you can also customize your weapons
thick so you can like add attachments
and stuff gown rifle we don't really
have anything to attach to anything yet
so we canvassed all right so let's go in
order because I called this the first 90
minutes and you know might as well yeah
started off or make sure we that before
we go yep
that's a good smart call yeah it looks
like a party of four Ron Swanson there's
also PvP ve where you fight each other
I saw one gameplay clip that we put up a
couple weeks ago from GDC I think that
was like almost like a king of the hill
but then there was like also like zombie
ways like yeah you say kind of had to
like manage it almost I don't want to
use gambit from destiny as an example
but that's another PvP ve where you know
you're dealing with zombo's I'm gonna
call them zombo's and then also other
players the game is $39.99 which I was
actually shocked I thought for sure it'd
be like $59.99 start from episode 2 y ou
will give this go in the wheelchair we
can always jump around are you got time
Johnny Ryles asking are you gonna stream
dreams so I thought about that as well
we do have these dreams early access but
I think I want to give it a day or two
to marinate in terms of just people
creating like cool stuff yeah we can
turn up that difficulty later on there's
so many zombies yeah this is the first
time I've ever give it a go like I'm
gonna keep it on it on normal the wait
first we all learn today I'm ready to go
it looks actually pretty good yeah she's
got sprint we've got I couldn't figure
out melee because you had that I thought
you know stick would be the react word
Nate lon I got a grenade launcher I was
doing it all wrong we got we can call
out where we want people to go nice
which shoulders okay so it's our one for
the melee
okay I like it hmm that's my c4k found
that that was l1 yep you pick it up no
don't think so
it's alright we don't need that so open
the store up and hope that it doesn't
cause it to blow up or bate some zombies
and use the c4 that's still we're doing
it this is where I guess all right oh
yeah yeah yeah bring it back to this
before
hey we're over here I do appreciate that
you can't like one into your teammates I
probably should so uh apparently you're
supposed to start off being quiet
silencer but like I'm not I'm not about
that this up us making
there's too many first Finland I do a
Paris fight a bit I'm expecting to have
like a comic at dynasty warriors kind of
feel for this tour just like no maybe
you'll find out about to see if they got
those like division ask like ammo boxes
you know we had to see for right now
grab by zombies I'll take that but the
silencer no your weapons hot oh so there
are caches there I don't know if they're
ammo cache okay arm ammo you got meds to
a scout you know you're gonna be a far
range
oh she more before oh they're on you I
think that's so that was a big that was
a big guy that you missed out on I hit
the button reminds me of a there's a
tiny teams version of Jackie duck he's
green oh hello yo help me so that's a
screamer okay like tank guy like the
juggernaut he's dead oh he died real bad
so this was kind of thinking this might
be like a manageable like high damage Oh
see ya
nailed it perfect we're headed
now you coming over gotta come down art
Vandelay I think we just got review
plates today so take a moment to get
actual like I don't have a date for that
important oh no that's a little sporting
working that's it's probably a burst
show single shot that's fine do it I
mean this games actually out today Jay
Johnson oh oh you laughing a larger what
it's a change right you're using Rama
okay you know what actually no I think
you should use it I don't know I don't
know how XP works in some like too many
options
Oh another chainsaw that's good chin
sauce for everyone along stop the
zombies are loud yeah I know right
I can turn it down a little bit Johnny
do you actually haven't played much
until today so I can't really tell you
if it's worth but again $39.99 so you
can tune in and see if you like what you
see
maybe that'll help you out oh heck yeah
oh yeah see I would just wanted out to
do that bed and I drop them down I'm
looking off that's gotta be a thing you
can knock down there's clear Oh Grenada
I'm ready for it now we're cooking with
gas
are they knock or need there's there's
so many in there that they're just like
absorbing it we need the paint off oh
boy
I mean it's got like a lot yeah oh yeah
c4 though do I see the late that's fine
see if there's oh yes yeah yeah you
can't climb if you don't have your
ladder so to speak I guess enjoyed that
you can kind of like shoot them yeah you
know it's actually just gonna ask you
the same thing I was like okay it made a
lot of sense
well there's when they had the pyramid
when they had the pyramid they're using
each other's scale not so much like you
know maybe they're just like digging
their hands and but no actually no that
doesn't I can't rationalize that at all
so good are the levels randomized like
left for dead I'm not sure first day
today playing it right now so bet big
bet I'm going to gamestop right now all
right well yeah Johnson you can also
just buy it online that's true should i
I should do it and pick this up oh yeah
pour it on there perfect
yeah bull is that one of those bigger
guys yeah they call it bull you've got
full on SWAT armor oh how come this guy
always back when he's back is his weak
spot it's cracked open okay we're
learning we're downloading it why can't
we connect to online services if you
look at the World War Z Twitter they
actually said they're having some
connectivity issues at least on ps4 and
YP is so neat Amy so they said that you
know they're looking into it they know
about it they're gonna try to fix it so
in the meantime you're just gonna have
to do what we're doing which is offline
co-op campaign co-op being the AI but at
least you can dip your feet in kind of
experience it maybe test out some
classes see if you like a certain one
we're playing the Hellraiser right now
so here's like a demo type o LMG yeah
that's the thing I'm going to need to
watch out there's a guy here left
creeper sorry yes he's done we're good
hey from Russia hi hello howdy
those are rocket launcher over there
left all right well turret action
build up the defenses they will not
cross these lines music music playing
helicopter maybe jamming out are they
coming this way though Oh prepare
defensive yeah yeah we've got got time
this is out today actually s Willits
a was good though you know killing
hordes of zombies swarms of zombies even
you stopped barbed wire no I think you
only get one at a time and I might have
actually dropped the one that I picked
up back here
or maybe it's just gone now oh is that a
bull maybe they're all shooting them
bring them to the turret trying to I'll
keep it over there yeah yeah it's one of
those hot swaps you know battle begins
and oh you guys I'm in the weak spot
there you go look at him rag doll
perfect person since last night nice
nice enjoy enjoy
how you liking it kill first you know
I'm connected to online you guys should
try it I can check on our alternative
ps4 I can also try to keep the Twitter
up to see if they you know or you have
any other day
watch this oh you have to like actually
taking uni I like it the light
machinegun it ain't no joke oh that's a
lot Oh has man he's a gassy boy that's
caustic we got and we're good
we should have laid c4 down my dude no
it will wait till you're close enough
and what's insane is just how many they
are how many there are rather yeah and
like it feels like you're rolling them
down and put a holy smokes there's so
many of them oh you could RPG later dude
yeah I just go and pick that up really
quick because I'm already on family or
are these shooting guys behind you too
oh very soon I like it they come from
you at all angles
we able to barbwire the other side no
okay maybe we should we do have a
turnover but you might have to
compensate you know old tower defense
Eric would tell ya hey you know you know
wrong that lien looks that Lane looks
pretty poised to hold up you know but
this are the turrets shooting I'm
hearing they're like little sirens going
off I think they're like trying there's
more guns behind you to it Oh big boy
you're right I think see you
that's not his weak spot hey Sean Auto
turret do something okay you got him
perfect made him run right in that car
are there any guns for you to hot swap
to the peddler will be in five minutes
okay cuz apparently this game also has
like an AI director kind of like left
for dead does where it'll it'll adjust
depending on what's going on with you so
if I trust in the director everything
should you though probably not okay
let's see I hit the button yeah there's
just 45 minutes ago all the last tweet
said was these connectivity issues so
some players and the team is or for some
players and the teams looking into it
thank you for your patience I will
double check though cuz it would be
pretty cool to coop obviously you okay
this game isn't working on ps4 you
talking about the online functions or
the offline because you can play offline
but as it stands right now I cannot
condense what I'll try to do is maybe
close up this side game that you guys
don't see and because I have another
piece boring here but you know it's fine
you still get a taste of what can you
wouldn't kid what you can't expect it's
really weird with explosives there's no
like roll option okay so just a
traditional running straight kind of
yeah which feels like a weird choice
because I feel like I should be able to
roll it's not a big thing I like in this
crossroad oh let's cross was really good
I was like oh no it's just give me a
silent crossbow but the nor matings
women reading it except like on droids I
guess they're like Splash Damage
maybe I guess I could do another one for
science just to be sure a smidge nothing
to be too I think I also take reduced
damage
nice as well it as I said earlier it is
the outer ring yeah and tell him
oh this is I don't know if this was Oh
gasps boy ass boy over here oh I can't
just bring oh all right I don't know
what caused that to happen but you did a
roll though did so oh my friend
chokeslam multiple choke slams to the
traveler people dai him in his spot he's
got a spot is right on his back point at
it for you it's right here the AI might
not be the way to do it okay I don't
only like 80% of your HP but that's okay
because there's no problem here ya know
there are that you just pass is it PvP
or PvE there's it's primarily PV oh I
wish it's a chair
there's PvE and then there's also PvP ve
so you couldn't med pack again if you
had to and then use the other way do it
I wanna say I'm gonna keep my
self-taught bump because I'm more
importantly these that's true and I
think with the Bulls you just got to
bait your teammates to get hit by it
because obviously they ain't helping you
out you know most I'm not hold onto this
crossbow let's cross bows crossbows
pretty cool yeah unless there's
something really good inside of the PA I
read um so ps4 online is not working not
currently not thine o although it kind
of like comes and goes cuz right now it
looks like I could party with you nope I
lost connection almost for a little
while so
and in Dai is fine until you got to do
something a little harder like Killam
yeah nobody think it's mainly meant for
you to be playing with friends or people
online so this guy though oh you're in
denial real Rey bad acity life it's you
know that's when you say you're gonna go
loud that's what happened yeah I mean I
would love to co-op but I can't right
now
but as mentioned it is they are aware of
it so they will consider a deal with it
and maybe by the time you guys get home
tonight like it'll be all good for you
guys but I would assume most people are
at work or at school
hey we got a screamer or a creeper came
out of nowhere
open the door we should like you like a
kick a sweet kick yeah right got supply
crates
a little crate oh we can't care anymore
they have to you guys deliver it to the
driver
do I actually deliver five by myself
because my teammates are controlled by
the computer does it say five it said
five for a second
sweet Petersen hasn't actually been down
from me that often lately Gregory I mean
outside of like having to do updates and
stuff I think I do five alone two clubs
did you hear the train driver when I
dropped that now either he's a gracias
and a really breathy voice and it was
really kind of off-putting that guy
no that's that's the Australian I think
that okay I'm gonna have to loosen that
out for this one just drop down
nearly
a town's please don't be when are we
gonna see that's or maybe it is the same
guy box I know is still vmk this week he
ran past me he's like that's when I feel
like I should be able to like roll back
after I like yeah put something on the
mic on the door open the door it's a new
day I feel like that shouldn't be like a
full-on hold to open the door yeah
good afternoon and goodbye later Lana
please take it easy girls like playing
left 4 dead a little bit I feel like
it's definitely influenced by that's an
inspiration problem from it oh I get
connectivity back is it there
nope it was there and then it wasn't so
maybe they're they're making headway on
like this all night late you guys are
late to the party early for us
you know really it's gonna take you
damage yeah
and we're just gonna blow everything up
take the damage hits these are
speedrunning tactics hellraiser tactic
for damage until he comes in I believe
in my team I don't believe in it I
believe in my team okay okay so maybe
not gonna just run headlong I do like I
can use them as like I checked Twitter
like very recently and I don't think
they know the last one is still an hour
ago creeper down it's developed by Sabre
interactive it's one more this would be
a lot more interesting I think if that
if my teammates and help you yeah we got
our one from AOA we know it's nice and
orderly though I like that yeah
it's me I'm here it is your girl no than
a good news though event is you've
gotten all the meds whereas your
teammates are all like on death's door
here
there you go you've done it again keeps
on cracking because we're really we've
been lucky to make it through oh yeah
nothing nothing's crashed so far which
is nice
Oh victory gave me that that Rita all
right how many stats to my name exactly
how much experience you get to put into
it
Andrei's Bilardo says I was playing this
yesterday and really enjoyed it so far
tonight yeah I mean I think that it's
kind of fun it could be as you had
mentioned I think if we were able to
co-op this would be definitely more
interesting experience I mean there's
still some fun to be had kind of with AI
but it's definitely a different oh yeah
it game when you kind of can co-op it'd
be much better if we were played this
level again why we're definitely playing
to see if it's if it does the rainbow we
can we can check it out later
if we really want to we leveled up we've
done it
okay well oh we leveled up okay so
you're right okay so specific weapons
you will then get xp for them hey we use
some heavy yeah yeah I got hollow Karma
also saying I was playing this all night
yesterday it was fun af cool alright so
got 150 so I can pick this up see four
will attract zombies for five seconds
after being planted that seems pretty
good you didn't even use this key for
that much though yeah I feel like I can
try to be more worried why don't you
back out and try another chapter maybe
that's so once you try to invite what we
have a watch watch try to party me and
it's not gonna work like hit triangle
fine match class party closed party
closer can you plus it that's weird
because I uh yeah yeah hit X on that
that's a oh nevermind I lost touch yeah
we're out it's fine so maybe try chapter
2 Jerusalem
let's hit check out another location
area a different squad of who we both
here got we've got Judd Whittaker who is
working with the press D name have a
flamethrower no flamethrower apparently
pulling to one Ethan wolf who that guy
looks sick
it looks like he's real mean Daniel he's
Daniel looks really well relax
he's like a mirage he's got like a real
like Big Boss kind of like fatigue so
you like it then writing down yeah yeah
oh is missing is the eye patch are you
gonna customize any weapon there
anything I don't think I can actually do
anything with my weapons yet okay does
not enough level any of the levels okay
yeah so we do have that new skill and we
are level two and I think a nice time
shoot your foot with the explosion you
know it probably will work you take a
small amount of damage but there's more
levels in New York I know there's more
levels I just figured we travel we just
travel around the world yes you see what
it looks like mix those mix it up yeah
would you like one chapter in each area
there's still Moscow and Tokyo and if we
end up making it through it maybe we
could circle back and see if the levels
are different yeah so research team were
cut off in the heart of the old city six
weeks later green gold is trapped and in
desperate need a rescue no got a rescue
a doctor so I never saw the movie but I
did read the book and this seems like it
is pretty in line with like what the
book kind of presented there's just
different stories of different people in
different places like wallet was
happening I watched a movie and I can't
really remember it other than the warden
seemed that like everyone remembers like
the helicopter scene that's about it
yeah do Tokyo next you want that's fine
we can do Tokyo before Moscow how's it
look
I think it's on is it epic story I think
it's on the epic story is dead if we
white it's only forty bucks which I
thought oh it's actually not 60 so I
hope they figure out the connectivity
stuff though because again as I
mentioned a lot of this fun for me on a
personal level when you go on so those
speakers so this is what you're supposed
to do the first time find something
inside of this crate oh cool yeah
so I'm ready to go if you hear about the
audio boxes though what they're talking
about yeah I can meet the loud speakers
already okay I thought one of them ahead
it's SMG silence how did you not react
at always like something's hitting me I
mean they're zombies soon I like that
head shots are like actual head shots
yeah they explode like I appreciate a
lot what do we got here yeah yeah combat
shotgun but you're so close to levelling
that oh my my I don't know I don't have
to be close but I mean I know you use it
for a bit I'm down I'm down to ride it
out
sad dude what's up Kevin uh-oh that's
gonna definitely bring them in right I
mean if we activate loud just because
I'm pretty sure we're just gonna have a
whole bunch of zombies come in but you
got to do it I'm ready for it
defend the checkpoint cool I mean you do
have the barbed wires set up good
there's more barbed wire here watch her
effing six he says I mean you know
sometimes you just got to let people
know hello don't forget your this yeah
although you have like mini keyboard
right now it's gonna see this is this
just range c4 here's how the there's one
that's like a straight-up melee class
the slasher you really try that out cuz
I'm sure that would be like the if you
are trying to use the oh yeah a part of
me wishes we had this game like a day or
two earlier just so that we could have
some work skills but it is what it is
hazmat guy I'm actually yeah this
crossbow is pretty legit
I like the crossbow what I don't know
but I'm looking out for whatever is oh
okay you got the grenade launcher
hasn't been to night look never - this
guy is it both of them and it looks like
both of them yeah uh yeah okay that's
the right person that's the right person
or is that just a messages that's just
all right got him
no oh my goodness how many of you are
there the bowl is a mighty piece if he
charges you better run it's weaker in
the back should make your shots count
got it
different no more of that I will get rid
all you slowly Oh
Oh
behind you guys
just when I say Taco Tuesday i wish i
was talking with you say here yeah right
gotta shoot the Screamers yeah black
might ask we haven't played enough to
really give you an informed decision I
would say try to watch and see if you
like it or not can you co-op on the same
system
I didn't some batters way too I don't
think this split screen right now a
visible man gaming we cannot but the
developers themselves have said that
there is kind of like online
connectivity issues right now so for now
we're just gonna have to play offline
hopefully maybe through this stream it
kind of stabilizes a bit and you can
tell up if we can we definitely will
have another PlayStation here set up if
not then we're just gonna have to ride
it out right out that offline campaign
their life we're gonna try to go to each
territory we were fully prepared to hang
out and do to cooperate yeah well yeah
right now we're in Jerusalem which is
like the second kind of like area or
story this area each act has multiple
chapters who nailed it
no no I thought I thought it was perfect
thought it was good at some point he's
gotta go down
right in the butt in the butt perfect
that's better his weak spot zip but oh
okay so you get a combat role off the
lights jumping off of something but not
actually you're like you can't do it
yourself I wanna be able to manually
roll help me prepare to defend the house
oh there's a table I try to put it
upstairs if I can I'm sure yeah
oh one guy's down he's fine it's fine
we're fine
so I'm feel like you're all gonna kind
of rushing back there yeah not fine oh
he's not dead you just downed right now
let a bull headshot see for him
I don't know if that's gonna hurt anyone
else
hello told you is what was your weak
spot the other guy got him see I thought
it would be like the back where it's all
yeah I don't know it looked like the
right play I wouldn't did the same you
should try to get ammo though or swap
gun a sniper rifle I'm almost out of
ammo for this I'll try this out
[Music]
that's where equipment is and come back
for that I'm gonna go back upstairs so
nice green gold is here I think you go
have you guys seen the crappy autumn
retro console is so ugly yeah I'm not a
big fan of that choice I'm okay my
question is how the heck is a VP on
there but I can't get that in the cat
dome beat him up it's a good question
it's not like the only reason why it
wasn't in the Capcom VM up was because
it was like licensed probably and so
like you know you wouldn't be able to
see like how can a sniper rifle be like
that great
[Music]
that's Karima you gotta kill the
Screamers he's over there and you got
the perfect gun for the tool for the job
oh he's around you got a lurker on hello
someone oh wow is this a scenario where
they have to help you think so well
Ethan's on his way
come on Ethan I believe in you the
Deacons a badass dude he looks like the
rain will succeed guy my pal he's
driving oh look at that what a boss we
go hide the corn if you'll really come
first they just hit me lady stop it and
now how are we supposed to even like hit
catch a grenade downtown you know what
yeah I I think yep she got him right I
think he's dead yeah snail am we drive
to repair this little mine no restock
him gamings I just bought the game it's
friggin awesome
yeah I'm having a pretty good time I
really wish I could play with you though
yeah same I could have been like I'm
coming we just saved yeah bad yeah it is
out Sapir this uh that rifle might have
been a bad choice I mean it's like a
semi-auto but like I just don't see why
you would ever scope yeah unless there
was like a screen where that you would
need a scope you know it's not as seeing
things that are far away
trying to just hit fire it
oh wow the Capcom liked console thing is
29 inches long yikes
boys it's got two dicks right yeah it's
like sort of like emulating a cab in a
way I'm curious what their plans are for
like expanding out because it's got a
usb on it
I shouldn't be out here actually
Invisible Man gay man this what you said
but you said something about it do you
think that's a fair statement I don't
know what the statement is though so you
gotta inform me and judge me big deal
Oh some come for you Ethan yeah you got
his back yeah I'm going to definitely
pick this back up carbines really more
make it's good I'm good no you can heal
then grab a blanket oh yeah yeah such a
smart move can you heal you can't heal
them right I think that the medic might
just be better at healing because that
wasn't say you should heal Judd sure
like last leg
look at his life oh yeah he's whatever
time to get out of here okay I get some
cases the briefcase with the codes it's
got the code we've got to get the codes
to the guy yeah I just I need to
remember that I have a melee yeah that's
actually pretty good
yeah I almost got to the your name to
invite you and then it was like you have
no judge having healing a battle rifle
is history birth oh that's fine
this is okay you guys got this I believe
besides we found that this doesn't work
nailed it
oh yeah air jumbos double me crying here
combo breaker breaker nice and we showed
you familiar yeah lurker in the zone
there are PvP elements but I think
that's a separate windows reach me
charge will do I find that briefcase
yeah you can chainsaw we didn't get to
use one yet but yeah slasher in this
game is OPA SF damn we gotta try him out
hey my hurry doesn't really matter for
the next level one can change that gotta
be level twelve to connect it's not made
by the people that made love for dead
saber interactive be ready to be an
Aggie downstairs we're currently playing
offline campaign because online is we
had mentioned earlier is having some
issues the devs are aware of it and
their work
so that someone else could grabbed by
this so I can get on that hot seat for
Oh gasps boys oh this is actually very
bad that's fine so if you shoot him in
the head
they don't gasp anything up and nudity -
OH
Philo D I had a role I did just be so
much better because I could just stare
in one direction combat damn where's the
screamer it's probably outside somewhere
I'm on my way out oh yeah I don't see a
clock ticking I don't see a clock
ticking you're liars just overreacting
you're full of it Oh preach this
we get out of the way that or don't
that's cool too what do we got going on
over here
oh I was able to say no almost I was
able to send to me vipers the hottest of
seconds and I was like no you can't
it's not it's not me seems like micro
LMG
by all its over there
I see it yes a thing pop up got it rag
dark
rag dolls very good
okay no it almost happens yep that's
exactly what it is
idiot ha ha that's a fence Oh juggle
again explosive arrows oh yeah if you
want to see PvP ve slayer gaming if you
go to our YouTube game spot gameplay
channel there's actually gameplay of the
PvP thanks got to drinking vodka oh I
should have waited to use it on that
that probably had some cool stuff in it
why there's a breach there yeah you can
even put a breaching charge on there
what wasn't the thing you breached just
like a weird submachine gun and some
else and do too much with it though is
there a way to go up there we go oh my
god stairs go up
it's playing vermintide as you know
recently it's a very good time yeah I
never got into that I know there's a
bunch of people that did we're continue
to work on this and let you know about
that very patient yeah I mean they're
they're definitely being responsive
looks like a lot of people are it's
right everyone just kind of like how
they call them gas bags yeah
hey they kill the gas bag where's the
goal of campaign I think it's just so
you get through different scenarios so
that you can level up and then you can
also increase difficulty but as you
level up you get skill tree stuff back
here and that allows you to do different
things with character clash and there's
like seven classes I think was it seven
seventeen
[Applause]
we got your stuff here we go the
helicopter love no mercy oh I was like I
heard him I know where it was because
right at my feet Oh try it there's so
many coming home I'm guessing that it's
gonna do it just don't shoot stir all oh
it's explosive
I like that
piss back so we can use it
pick up nerds no nailed it done it just
Oh battle rifle is the pulse rifle we're
sorry the verse right you pick that up
just to get me go okay yeah that's good
it's got a good sound to it you know how
bad do you want it though that's just a
health kit I think you can get out
though I need that I really get to the
choppa yeah I still feel like we're
gonna do like a holdout for the
helicopter to show up or like the
helicopter is getting
payload rifles back chainsaw chainsaw
yeah no I don't have a heavy weapons for
chainsaw oh here we go let's do it Oh
chop the leg off
yeah I'm okay with this
I got 90 more swings man we gotta
eliminate this screamer sums are
breaking into the helico chute
definitely breaking into the house I
didn't sit over there the choppa I don't
you know I got a run over there or
something
I'm hoping this goes back
oh my job you got two seconds rip all
right I think Lee ripped I can't no I
can't go up there or maybe we just
failed an objective because instead
defend the helicopter and you exit out
or maybe
I'm still here they got the base as a
dog week now oh there's the scream
oh hello hi everyone
good to see you oh these or know you
just gotta kill all that tough there's a
budget you have some more c4 give me one
more nailed it
disconnected I think I did it I think of
one no you got disconnected
I shot what I thought was an explosive
barrel and that might have been too much
that it might have been too much I'll
see all right I don't think you got to
finish that one I don't think I did
either to get like more character
Laura's that way that's marked oh
there's a whole story for each character
I guess oh if you finish a thing maybe
you get like their movie to learn about
them that's interesting okay
yeah alright Moscow or Tokyo it is a soy
bean I didn't well I mean I I got extra
stuff and it also gave me the next level
/ cuz I'm level 3 now so it actually
gave me stuff from what I got kicked out
which is pretty nice but let's try being
a slasher Tokyo gonna be a slasher it
was a final call there only to to accent
stuff
who we got here who are characters okay
I like that there Sean from Japan God
can you go tap to oh that's too low and
it all gg oh yeah it's real cool throw
it through your singer Anatomy
oh yeah well he looks like he's gonna be
the right person to pick for slasher so
yeah I'm gonna go with that okay all
right cool cool I think we are set do it
yeah it's like it's only fun for a few
hours I could probably play this with
friends a whole bunch I get C's it's
inking a deal eh away a chapter or an
act or something you can increase
difficulty there's also the PvP ve
although says they're new here welcome
yes glad you stopped by two games my
life yeah you live Monday to Friday
well I mean a.m. Pacific Standard Time
if you didn't know you should know now
cuz I told you you should subscribe
subscribe miss a single show we do
exactly even ring the bell
I wanted to scheme drop last night came
out officials a bunch of stuff that came
out today overwatch rising event up yeah
rest in peace Joey you got file fancy
xx2 on the switch which I was almost
gonna do oh sorry
early access Final Fantasy 14 has it's a
fantasy 15 crossover
there could still be people in these
houses this looks really nice I like it
all right so what's your slasher what's
your so I probably should look at what I
had is like a thing but also this is
just the beginning of that snow probably
isn't we've done what we can his show
evacuation is over see you
I do like they'll like weird like
zombies though jeez Chris PAP says in
cash experience that for the beginning
heard the ps4 news question where we
talk about ps5 yeah we know about these
five MK 11 next week oh boy
yep looking for that for sure
just to subscribe to and hit the bell
thanks game with dad heck yeah I wonder
if I can actually do it with like a
whole bunch I wonder if that speak
that's like how get in you know yeah
feel like he has more animations maybe
he did have like a little bit of a lunch
which was kind of new issue I wonder if
I could ski mouth it's out Nathan I
thought there's a girl like a stealth
kill animation or something you could do
this is insec util oh man oh oh she's
vomiting blood not good
hey what's your aim
oh so you can actually I don't know if
it actually just damage but I appreciate
that they call you out for us Austin
Dougherty it's we've only been playing
perfect so it's hard for me to tell you
if you should buy it or not but I mean
you can keep watching and see if it you
don't have what people call didn't know
they'd say no that's fine yes I time to
go out on the bus yeah so I would say
watch see if that helps you make a
decision unfortunately you can't show
you the PvE PvE
but we have a gameplay clip on our
gameplay channel you get my gameplay you
want to check that out to see what that
looks like but what I remember was kind
of like king of the hill is like 4v4 and
then there was Ami's as well Xbox one
act or one sorry Xbox one ps4 and PC pcs
epic store Oh
maybe use them first yeah they got to
protect the bus that's heavily barbed
wired Oh a little okay so maybe you can
find a bunch of other kind of stun up
yeah like that yeah tell him
yeah mow him down with the chainsaw
chainsaw is pretty good man they just
follow you and not the bus they're
attacking the bus yeah I'm pretty oh
yeah the arts I just look at the
mini-map and I just see red yeah there
is that [ __ ] anywhere save the bus
did it something I got some wow I'm
talking about brings more than this
there's stuff behind the beat
screamer screamer good guy took him out
we did it weighed it down that screen
well you got a bunch of charge
make sure you give him a katana sword
yeah I agree
maybe the reason it was in The Watchmen
thought to a little splash previously
Plus needs a fire shield on about that
so you could single player can offline
campaign like we are right now or you
can co-op with others you can co-op with
online players as well Joe my man yeah
that's what I would definitely yell when
I taser a zombie yeah I just got to the
end of Moscow no crashing laughs I'm so
sorry one it kind of crashed on us just
now in the first act is a Jerusalem when
we're at the helicopter yeah
I don't know when I'd use it the bus the
bus doesn't have enough already
I'm just kidding I'm pretty sure you can
yeah
nice the Ottoman no he's not he did just
pick that up cause we're about to move
yeah there's no split-screen co-op where
I would be doing that
save the bus and escorted me or the
chainsaw do
you know put some barbed wire up here
well I can slide that by publisher again
I've actually heard a whole bunch of
gorillas lamech maybe there's gotta be
like a creeper or something like nearby
Chinatown yeah
come on through what are you doing well
I have to be on it to move it that's all
yeah yeah oh we forgot the barbed wire
down well then it's okay this means I
get to shoot things quicker what's up
the manual funny hider is this the
divisions obvi but now
come on through
Paducah be halfway through the whole
show is just yeah what big gun
oh right okay
chainsaw have there been a lot of
reports of crashes I mean Ivan we've
only had to crash once and then one
person in chat also said it crashed on
them
the only thing I really know of as an
issue right now is the connectivity to
online servers which save address or not
address sorry
announced on their Twitter so we're kind
of waiting for that line is asking not
that I want to be the one to ask what is
their monetization element so I don't
see anything you know yeah from the
menus themselves there's no like store
or anything it's either co-op campaign
multiplayer and then the collections are
like your character stuff the weapons
for those frag grenades masking gas
grenade Molotov c4 claymore mines supply
bags that look explosive stun gun and a
stim pistol
those are equipment oh my god save save
me scream what's up on top of the bus
they're coming to bring this barrier
down Oh watch out I thought I could
outrun him I couldn't rope on them at
all no not those guys that's their job
the lurker yeah yeah we're currently
playing offline with bots that's how you
have to play offline watched it didn't
botch that one
just open why is the gate you guys
defend it
uh-uh is there any defenses that you
didn't see oh not often that
yes 16 seconds to prepare to defend them
but I don't think there's a lot I will
[ __ ] medkit in than that KITT this is
why not
is there loot in this game I mean
there's this kind of stuff that you
would need to kind of use to defend or
kill zombies if that counts as leap I'm
not sure if this game has a platinum oh
my goodness that's a lot I wish that
canister 'blow-up-able should be should
should be should be man I really I know
they're like loadout and you gotta love
it and also like the other barrier
[Music]
chat who's played like how does is the
slasher supposed to have something
that's like oh my lord
homicide use the turret that you
deployed oh is it it's not an auto
turret that would explain it
get everyone off of the thing I thought
it was Auto again get off of me don't
forget your r1 I need to definitely do
this we got it don't worry we thought it
was an auto turret we didn't need it
anyways well it's cool that you can do
that well behind oh good that that fixed
it
everything's good they need it anyways
now we know for next time ya should pay
more attention to it I guess that they
gave us so many auto turrets in the
beginning I'm just like oh yeah this is
the only thing you've got available
it would be interesting to see if it is
like Auto generators or I think you got
to be next with my babe yeah
because this means the all funnel next
to the bus defend the bus
yeah so actually I could look it up
myself I don't know why I'm asking you
guys when I could pull it up myself
show me the slasher okay slasher starts
with a stun gun and compact SMG performs
additional melee strikes before becoming
tired okay dude - hold on I got booted
for a second so I can't read anymore
yeah melee strikes damage to targets
instead of one Oh and eventually you can
get crowd control as a thing that your
first perk which is push radius from
melee attacks increased by 50%
movement speed penalty when zombies are
very close to reduced so you can run
even more okay more zombies required to
pin you down
I don't need an increase this is done
gun duration that's pretty good he's
drained and target count your base
target count can be up to 15 okay at one
time oh wow and then once you get higher
level you unlock like slice and dice
which makes everyone on your team have
more than one melee well that's good
let's try uh just try this this bullpup
seems lessened I guess eventually you
just have more melee strike so like once
you get to like Blademaster you have
four oh wow
I do like like now that I understand
that like it has a cleave that that
makes me kind of want to roll around a
bit more not for him probably who a
double-barrel shotgun as a secondary
yeah I'm gonna give it a go
I'm not sure if it's a kind of exclusive
for epic it has to take a look there's
special zombies only on different a lot
of guns everybody's high panic bad
combination
see everybody was high
it's an interesting observation do you
heal your teammates or do you just let
it be you can no I know I'm just asking
you right now in your current situation
with chemical and show I mean I guess
sure - too busy focusing on just trying
to make it through myself Oh worked out
see ya there we go
the box next to it doesn't open are
there are a whole bunch of boxes in this
area that seem like they're just oh oh
no worries Santiago please if you see
something you know the answer to it's
not you want to help out that's really
great heck yeah
thank you so forget your stun gun later
yeah
or is the screen up there typical screen
where what's hiding out on top of the
bush I really like how this looks I wish
that the green gas cloud was more
visible okay I'm into that was a good
gun okay I mean this is true I can't
argue this fair playing on playstation
right now I was really hoping to try to
co-op but it's kind of touch and go
servers developers know they've been
telling people they were working on it
so although no the bridge just shook and
I don't like that every time I'm like
yeah I said your name by Konnor it's
down for most people assemble who's that
guy that's our new friends it's the
military yep we need okay
automatic turret there's one more well I
can only carry one so remember we did
this last time it up delete are those
like the kind you have to reload to
manually think so
yeah days gone is until that no one so
you can put one on the the witch won't
call it see you later I want one up here
actually I was like kind of going for
the higher areas this is probably gonna
be anyway got all the supplies hey dub
screamer down the screamer oh he's
really in doing he's not doing his a gun
is a gun line anymore with a nice
special heavy Oh used to have a minute
to defend prepared to defend the game
just trying to look around and see what
else I can find
I think there's only one other place I
can put barbed wire to over it's all
back here let's put it right in front of
that bus because I think that's what
we're gonna be trying to defend
some other one over here
um border or well I'm definitely putting
that up here do you think you have to
manually do that one probably this way
I'll have the turret to cover me while I
do the mortar we got another grenade
launcher over here don't need a heal
that's good this is good this is fine
there's another morning show I could
there's so much more you need some human
meet you it's true there's part of me
that's like man I there's three more
having not having a micromanage this is
a yes yeah here you go there we go
servers are not working you can only
currently play like okay so coming this
way I was looking the wrong way
we only got code today John Legend so
review is probably gonna pick up oh
that's a bit well I wouldn't say a bit
but it's gonna not be out that soon good
how about that
okay okay switching to mortar although
there's no
[ __ ] those bad far away
we're good did that looking at a book no
it's back up so my goal or any mortar
actually shoot I wanted to the parking
Lyman for the girl nice one shot okay -
where's gate - there's a second gate
this whole time we've been oh so you
shoot at the bottom of it they all
topple down which is kind of gonna
battle their fish in a barrel
I thought I could get away another
screamer across the way
oh this is when I can use this yeah yeah
I saw I definitely something no I wasted
it all well then I gotta put the fence
up
I can do it I can do it I can do it
pretty her bad idea this is fine
that thing needs to be reloaded to your
left there's no one left also kill the
screamer point me on the other side
there we go or go hey you know if if
they decide to come back through there
no no I meant the screen where that was
in the parking lot cuz he in the parking
lot well there was one unless they
killed them now it's behind you now so
he's looking at the one that was up over
this way yeah but there's also gate two
they're gonna have to go back to there
over there there's a lot of turrets over
here to take care of whatever is that is
that's some I don't need the hot reload
let's do that as a drive-by
oh no okay good
the good thing you put that's hurt up
yeah right you have a second
yeah that wasn't good enough that's
because I put the fence it's also
because you didn't know to put up the
fence sooner I feel like I should have
though I feel like I should have known
from the start that there was a gate too
because it probably was some sort of
defense I could put up to help make it a
bit easier but that's fine
let's join yeah you live and learn
that's the theme song for Sonic
Adventure 2 but we do get progress so do
you not even get to keep going I guess
not them upper guns okay got the
crossbow too
yeah we're only on one start right now
but you can scale difficulties yeah
what has mentioned first time kind of
really playing the game so I just want
to experience it kind of learn see
what's going on so we're gonna go to the
last area which I guess is Moscow yeah
yeah and call it a scream
you have enough to level something up to
if you have to Moscow from above poor
characters here Naruto Uzumaki barrage
more or less GOG a bunch in the bunches
on oh she's got a real rad coat I'm in
pick her just because of that all right
I'm gonna be and be her just look at
class stuff I can buy something I kinda
want to go back to it's my demolition
setup oh that's a good thing take that
I'm just gonna go back to hell raiser
okay say it made the most sense I feel
like having explosives definitely a good
thing I think we might be able to
customize weapons now oh you can give
these these attachments and realized
that they were like actual trees oh that
gold one you see how I get that water
bundle for that alright so probably
can't get any of these but what we're
trying I just want to see what the cross
boat does okay go there we go
also just adds a scope to it and adds
power oh wow and accuracy dang alright
cool
I like that's the thing I can do and I
think we're good I'm gonna hit let's do
it
I'm just gonna give up on the side cause
there's no point fair enough
uh yeah I mean just for my limited
playing this has been in my opinion from
playing both or sorry playing Overkill's
Walking Dead for like 45 minutes to an
hour versus watching this and having
played 10 minutes of this I think this
is better than that
I think this is better than that -
that's a limited small sample size but I
feel pretty confident in saying that
like I don't you know what I want to see
is a gtfo
yeah I'm very curious about that and
then also aren't the left 4 dead guys
doing something - oh yeah it's it's not
a left 4 dead game but it's something
with a similar name like outside of what
they're normally doing all right
listen it's helicopter shots what I want
to throw being quiet out the window from
the start I'm not saying that just
because everything's already rushing
what's going on here getting spammed
right now people people seem to be
really excited about zombies I'm putting
that in timeout sounds like a good plan
I haven't you look like a zombie for a
second our like how it's universe
everyone calls him gas bags
yeah I'm trying Chad there's too many of
them oh my god something was there that
that zombie type more than another one
does their job yeah apparently the
turtle rocks to do folks are doing a
game called back for blood back for
blood there it is
it's still got like the the four in it
okay there's a lot of popular justing
there for a second
we don't do scores puia we're just
pretty much on the video team so don't
score them just playing oh good night
sting that one was pretty fast yeah
apparently I get I think when it gets
harder they get faster so what someone
in chat was saying okay oh you know what
we should I did we should've did one for
fun at six
I mean I'm tell me how nutty it is I'm
done started up cuz it probably won't
last very long oh you mean right now
I mean if you want to do
part of me wants to see it I knew to
actually be the same level though as
earlier to see let's do it let's do it
right
later Santiago thanks for coming by
we're gonna all right we're for science
because we have 10 to 15 minutes left
we're just gonna straight up crank it up
to 6 difficulty and we're gonna go back
to like I don't know which one did you
like the most
mmm I would say Tokyo might have been my
favorite iron but I don't know if we
should go back to because we just played
ok cuz I say maybe the one you failed
yeah I don't know disconnected from yeah
the Jerusalem right yeah uh it's pretty
fun the one reborn I think it'd be more
fun ways to New York with New York had a
lot of really other players instead of
the AI I think the AI is just whatevs
you still level up and all that which is
important but I think that the best or
more preferred way to play would
probably def would definitely be with
either other co-op people or friends of
you know whoever's playing with you
alright so we need to change this insane
oh yeah unforgiving recommend it for
classes above level 25 what's very hard
do they eat ramen soup yeah yeah just
okay so it does have its own kind of
like like hey maybe you shouldn't do
this way a little warning we're level 3
let's go yeah I'm ready for it let's uh
let's see how it goes if it ends up
being real rough let's just go back and
do a different one
definitely not a single player with
[ __ ] charging like that yeah yeah it
it's definitely uh more of a multiplayer
game do you have to take the AI yes
it ought Oh Phil's the the team it's a
it's a four-person party or what or
whatever so bullet range damage drop-off
not that I've noticed
there's just a new left4dead it's not
the new left for dead but it's
definitely got a lot of left for dead
things going for it
nobody's leaving anybody what are the do
you think I'm gonna survive the first
wave that's that's the real question
I don't know let's see if the AI is
better on hard and if the level changes
there is co-op online with Robert but
right now they're having like kind of
like server issues so we can't do that
unfortunately no what sucks is the AI
doesn't scale with you you know they're
your level one from what I saw that's
not good okay gotta go silent you hear
me yeah do they not die in one head
touch I know they did that's is missed
okay body shots real rough don't
recommend them
anything is I don't remember when the
first warm was I think it was just
because I started like going louder from
the beginning like right in here oh that
oh wow the damage is real behind for
fine this is okay oh you're going loud
okay oh they're already here I'm trying
to like not go forward grab what you can
and regroup at the elevator okay
I wouldn't say they're bastards but they
definitely hurt quite a bit while your
teammates are doing a good job of not
getting hit though yeah what's up
Jonathan better late than never really
hoping it holy crap
hey Sean took so much damage from that
creeper sure I'll take this I actually
like it more than the shotgun which is
weird because I'm very into shotguns
damage is real I'm ready for the the
black olive we just got it today so
probably not for a few days I don't know
oh he's in the elevator okay
he ran into something
very tanky oh yeah and there's friendly
fire in this mode - so I've like try not
to shoot we had me my teammates well
there you go
see you later just kidding adios oh this
is where you got this those sick tricks
you see them running across they haven't
moved yet
oh no there's a bunch on the street oh
yeah they're not actually they can't
Thanksgiving Parade hope you see upward
oh yeah close enough it's saying they're
piling up what are you gonna do do the
drops I should probably take the
crossbow that's your BAE finally got on
that tack so you didn't okay so hard to
start with it yeah you're gonna start
with one that's the end of any iron
setting or just three there's I just get
to do this I don't know if it's
something you're gonna scope you can
actually look through it you do sniper
scopes all right what's the play here
you're gonna drop the things are you
gonna all do you manned have your
silencer anymore
I don't know I do okay cool so you can
at least kill weed these guys out
maybe there is damage drop off cuz yeah
they're taking a way more damage right
yeah unless you had shot him I think ya
body shots are the tickles unless you
got a whole squad shooting paintballs
here we go yeah you got a head shot so
this this difficulty definitely promotes
getting the head shots I would assume
you get more experience though doing a
harder difficulty yeah I think so one
would have to imagine all right it's
like a Black Friday sale that's that's
true yeah those guys haven't started
moving
oh there's some sleeping he's sneaking
okay so you got clear that one's in the
atrium which we're gonna do by shooting
these young more Nimmons shoot the
ornaments for it I just watch one of
them oh maybe they are faster holy I
need to get to the other side it's the
show my lord
okay all right that's fair okay so the
ornaments was a bad idea I guess I mean
or maybe do you save that for them you
safer than that for the cool better you
know no I don't think I would have hit
ya stay right next to you sure the AI
seems either more durable or something
because they've been able to kind of
yeah okay that works right in the leg
let's find the gases over there now I
guess I'm just gonna watch the sides
I shouldn't have ran on top of that yeah
this way oh the splash damage doesn't
seem that bad so no Molotov now you guys
have c4 though do just should have been
using okay that could have went better
but it wasn't as bad as I thought it
would be well like I said surprisingly
the AI is is at least making up for it
in the sense that there's as strong or
as smart as the AI zombies I guess yeah
see how it all works out when it comes
to this defensive no idea I didn't space
I think this would have to be successful
first I think you got to heal your
teammate yeah they deserve it this time
around or who needs a first come here
we'll go in and one for yourself yeah
cuz I don't know how many times I can
get down and I think I might be yeah
they're pretty pretty nutty actually I
should probably give it away because I
can I can try to self preserve myself
more again we haven't played enough for
me to say if it's worth it or not I
don't want to go there I think that if
you enjoy you know left4dead
desk style games and you wanna it's like
you grab that lady buy that right now
we're not to buy it you get it forever
yeah careful with these guys never know
sleeping I think should try to get wire
on both sides this time yeah all the
tank okay that's fine I'll take the
other way
oh come on guys yeah perfect baited okay
that barbed wire
there's Auto turns - I think yeah I
really enjoy mulling down countless
enemies all this is for you then it's
got that the dynasty warriors it was
kind of like there's two explosive
rifles and there's a metal to as well
good to medkits dos medkits
yeah 32 seconds left
put this one yeah so there's a heavy
there's also another attack here I guess
I don't know if there any any other
boxes I think you should make it and
then pick up the other make it that's a
good call no don't give it to him it's
probably think it's on the same bud
all right feel like they gave you two
turrets last time yeah well maybe harder
difficulty oh you don't have six shots
my dude it's fine I can grab the one
next to me and then I'll run over and
grab the other thing I actually pick
them off here it's a can
yeah you've become the turn on the other
side exactly check it out yeah pick it
me a hundred shot behind me naughty gas
pulls up person nice
I do really badly Oh Auto turret saving
the day there's a heavy shotgun like Oh
needs ammo come on little buddy I
believe in you yeah there's that shock I
think immediately I run up and grab it
all the bearers are already down
one more biome 22 shots in your chakra
now that you're gonna count it it's good
to know
it might be okay there's probably one
more bowl that we gotta take care of
thanks okay sit down to the subway yeah
I'm just reloading everything I just
don't want any stragglers to pick you up
yeah all right so this is level six
difficulty testing it out it tells you
you should probably be like level 25
we're level three level three so not
crazy to think is undoable however like
I said the AI seems to have gotten very
comparable to the enemy AI I wonder if
like we had like coordination with
people it'd be easier if the AI is
actually doing oh man that guy picked up
quite he did
I don't want to like push too far ahead
worried kind of guess uh yeah 15 shot I
got that submachine gun
it's how easily I miss just like that I
guess look just trying to look for like
more eight stuff everywhere
auto charities Brad Pitt
oh this is the five grief
yeah I'm Donna give it a go
I got everything behind him get on my
way so I can shoot him
oh there we go that's fine
oh my okay we're all down hey every five
five bullets a dream Yeah right this
might be where it all comes but all the
other things are on the train though all
the charges are although ammo
it's true there's a lot of human stuff
yeah you know I'm gonna use the assault
rifle
no meds twelve supply crates my dude
I though wicket it's your left wait
lament oh yeah one of your buddies my
green where I can't get in there oh I
feel like this might be it no no no get
this look we're coming up oh he's not a
one shot anymore what are you doing oh
she's a zombie oh I was supposed to
shoot her look at her her stand-in there
wait wait they're all zombies and that's
uh that's hard mode for you all just so
thanks for tuning here thanks for tuning
into the World War Z stream yeah yeah
again I think that unfortunately the
servers are having issues developers
know they're working on it so we'll
check out you know when we can co-op
stuff but I think again as we had
mentioned earlier it could be a good
amount of fun if you can you know just
play with some folks you know either
online or either your friends or
whatever
unfortunately no split-screen co-op so
yeah check it out today
$39.99 epic game store ps4 Xbox one and
stay tuned there's a to their Twitter
probably to find out if you know they've
resolved the kind of like online
connectivity
thank you everyone to tuning in we
really appreciate it to GameSpot live
again live Monday to Friday 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time
come back tomorrow we'll be back more
games more fun and until then me and Ben
say goodbye bye bull stick to be cool
stay in school or puts on rock is a bye